Hey gang, you know we like to keep our podcast PG. Well, I blew it on this one guys, I'm sorry. So we wanted to warn you before you listen in case you're listening with your kids around the 20 minute mark, Angela goes off the rails. Well, hey, wait a second, I just tell a story about an episode of Fear Factor. There's no other way to tell it. There's some adult subject matter. You told it how you needed to. And you might want to,
嘿，各位，你们知道我们喜欢把播客节目维持在PG级（家长指导级）。好吧，我在这集里搞砸了，大家，对不起。所以我们在你们收听前想提醒一下，以防你们和孩子们一起听。在大约20分钟的时候，安吉拉彻底失控了。好吧，嘿，等一下，我只是讲了一个关于一集《惊恐夺标》（Fear Factor）的故事。没有别的办法来讲述它。里面有一些成人话题。你用了你需要的方式来讲述它。而且你可能想，
you know, put your muffs on the kids at the 20-minute mark. Turn it down, skip five minutes ahead, whatever you need to do, and for the rest of you, enjoy. I'm sorry. I'm Jennifer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hi, Anj.
你知道的，在20分钟处把孩子们的耳朵捂上。把音量调小，快进五分钟，做任何你需要做的事，至于其他人，尽情享受吧。我很抱歉。我是珍妮。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你独家制作终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。嗨，安吉。
Hey, Jenna. Why are you looking at me like that? Because I have some sciatic pain in my hip. Oh, Lord, is this how we're starting today? Yeah. All right. What else you got? Well, I was trying to stretch it and you told me I had to sit down. You guys, she was kicking her leg in the air.
嗨，珍娜。你为什么那样看着我？因为我臀部的坐骨神经痛犯了。哦，天哪，我们今天难道要以这个开头吗？对啊。好吧，你还有什么？好吧，我刚才想拉伸一下，然后你告诉我必须坐下。大家伙们，她刚刚在空中踢腿。
It was comfortable. But you felt good. You think you can do that for 45 minutes? I think I can, yeah. Okay, go. You go, girl. I thought I could kick my leg and do this podcast at the same time, but Angela told me to sit down. I did, because I sat down.
这样很舒服。但你感觉好点了吗。你觉得你能保持那个姿势45分钟吗？我觉得可以，真的。好吧，开始吧。加油，女孩。我本以为我可以一边踢腿一边录这个播客，但安吉拉让我坐下。我照做了，因为我坐下了。
I didn't say it like that. I was like, hey, you're gonna hurt yourself, be, I don't think I can concentrate. Why did you kick your foot up like that? All right, well, I might need to do it midway, but let's get started. Okay, Jenna. Wait, when you do it midway, I'm gonna film you
我不是那样说的。我是说，嘿，你会伤到自己的，第二，我觉得我没法专心。你为什么要那样把脚踢起来？好吧，我可能在中间需要再做一次，但我们先开始吧。好的，珍娜。等等，当你中途做这个的时候，我要拍下你，
and I'm gonna put it on office ladies. All right, dot com. All right, today we are talking about the carpet. Ooh. It is season two episode 14 written by Paul Lieberstein, aka Toby, and directed by Victor Nelly Jr. Yeah. I'm gonna give you a summary.
然后我要把它放到office ladies网站上。好啦，网址.com。好啦，今天我们要聊的是地毯。噢。这是第二季第14集，由保罗·利伯斯坦（即托比）编剧，维克托·内利少优执导。耶。我来给你们做个总结。
Do it. In this episode, someone leaves a gift on Michael's carpet. You could call it that in his office. It is soft. Yeah. It is smelly. You're going to describe it. It is brown, gross.
说吧。在这集里，有人在迈克尔办公室的地毯上留下了礼物。你在他的办公室里也可以这么叫它。它很软。对。它有异味。你这就来形容它。它是棕色的，恶心的。
But the question is who done it? Michael is determined to find out everyone's a suspect. He suspects everyone in the office. To keep a close eye on the office, he takes over Jim's desk, which forces Jim to go work at an empty desk right next to Kelly, and Jim quickly learns why Kelly works in the back by herself. But the biggest surprise of this episode
但问题是，是谁干的？迈克尔决心查个水落石出，每个人都是嫌疑人。他怀疑办公室里的每一个人。为了密切监视办公室，他占用了吉姆的办公桌，这迫使吉姆去凯莉旁边的一个空办公桌工作，而吉姆很快就明白了为什么凯莉总是独自一人坐在后面。但这一集最大的惊喜
might be that you finally see Pam and Roy getting along. They've come back from a vacation and they're all giggly. They're giggly. They've been in the polk anos. Yeah. Which I googled, it's only about 51 minutes from Scranton. And is it snowy?
可能是你终于看到帕姆和罗伊相处融洽了。他们刚度假回来，一直在咯咯笑。他们一直在傻笑。他们去过波科诺斯山了。对。我谷歌了一下，它离斯克兰顿只有大约51分钟的车程。那儿有雪吗？
It's snowy because this was January and here are the best activities. Because I went down the rabbit hole of the polk an nose. Now I want to go to the polka nose. It's beautiful. In the winter, here are the best activities to do in the polka nose, right? One hour away from scranton, snow tubing, skiing, snowboarding, a casino, snowmobile, ice skating, snow chewing, there's a brewery and a spa.
有雪，因为这是在一月，这里是最佳活动。因为我深入研究了波科诺斯山。现在我想去波科诺斯山了。那儿太美了。在冬天，这里有去波科诺斯山玩的最佳活动，对吧？距离斯克兰顿一小时车程，雪地轮胎滑雪、滑雪、单板滑雪、赌场、雪地摩托、溜冰、雪地咀嚼，还有啤酒厂和水疗中心。
Oh, I bet Roy went to the brewery. Yeah, I mean. I mean, yeah. That's for sure. They pretty much did that in the casino. Jim asked Pam if she did a lot of skiing and she says not really. Yes, a little, a little, a little. All right, are you ready for some fast facts? I am. And then at some point, Jenna, you'll have to let me know with your sciatic and all of that business. Yeah, I do have a gift for you. You do? Yes. And I want to share it with you rightica and all of that business. Yeah. I do have a gift for you. You do?
哦，我敢打赌罗伊去了啤酒厂。对，我是说。我的意思是，是的。那是肯定的。他们在赌场里基本上也就是这么干的。吉姆问帕姆她经常滑雪吗，她说不太经常。是的，一点点，一点点，一点点。好了，你们准备好听快速冷知识了吗？我准备好了。然后到某个时候，珍娜，你得配合你的坐骨神经痛和所有这些事情提醒我一下。好的，我确实有一份礼物要送给你。真的吗？是的。我想把它送给你，伴随着所有这些……痛和所有这些事情。是的。我确实有一份礼物要送给你。真的吗？
Yes. And I want to share it with you right here with all of our office ladies listeners because y'all been listening. Oh my gosh, who am I? I should tell you guys, my sister Janet from Texas has been here for a week. And so I just said, y'all been listening. Yeah. When you two get together, you get all Southern.
是的。我想把它送给你，就在这里送给我们所有的《办公室辣妈》听众，因为大家一直在收听。哦，天哪，我是谁？我应该告诉你们，我来自德克萨斯州的姐姐珍妮在这里待了一周。所以我刚才说，大家一直在收听。是的。当你们两个聚在一起时，你们就变得满嘴南方腔了。
I get very Southern. So anyway, you guys will get it. You'll be in on the joke, and that's why I want to give it to you like during a podcast. Do you want to give it to me right now before we start with FastFacts? I guess we should after I've said all that. That's a big buildup.
我变得非常南方腔。所以不管怎样，你们会懂的。你们会心领神会这个笑话，这就是为什么我想在播客期间把它送给你。你现在就要在开始“快速冷知识”之前把它送给我吗？在我说了这么多之后，我想我们应该这么做。这铺垫得可真大。
Let's do it. You're probably really curious. Oh, it's wrapped in bubble wrap, just like Michael's foot from the injury. Look at you with your little office call back. That's right. You guys that have been listening know that Jenna hasn't really seen Star Wars and it's okay. I've come to terms with this you guys. I don't like scary movies. Right. This is an impassant our friendship. What are we
我们开始吧。你可能真的很好奇。哦，它包了气泡膜，就像迈克尔受伤的脚一样。看看你，还用上了小小的《办公室》梗。没错。一直收听的各位都知道，珍娜其实没有看过《星际大战》，没关系。我接受这个事实了，大家。我不喜欢恐怖电影。没错。这是我们友谊中的一个僵局。我们该
gonna do? We don't know. So anyway, but you did say you love Star Wars sort of memorabilia in there. I do. You were Princess Leia for Halloween as a kid. Yeah. Right? All right. So remember my little baby Yoda? No. My crochet baby Yoda. Stop it.
怎么办？我们不知道。所以不管怎样，但你确实说过你喜欢里面的《星际大战》相关纪念品。我是喜欢。你小时候万圣节扮过莱娅公主。对吧？好。所以，还记得我的小尤达宝宝吗？不记得。我钩织的小尤达宝宝。别这样。
Stop it. Okay. So I have to give a huge shout out to Shay. Oh! He crocheted this. He is one of my insta-pal friends. His name on Instagram is Oh Shay, what is it? It's four on fleek. Am I saying that right? I hope so. But he heard how much you
别这样。好吧。所以我必须对谢伊表达巨大的感谢。哦！这是他钩织的。他是我的Instagram好友之一。他在Instagram上的名字叫“噢，谢伊，叫什么来着？”是四个“on fleek”。我没说错吧？希望如此。但他听说你有多
loved mine and Jenna. Oh, he made you one. Look at him. Baby Yoda. Oh my god. And it's a little crib and it's crocheted by hand. And look, it's a Christmas ornament. Well, you know know two of my favorite things are Christmas decor. And handmade Christmas stuff. You must have that. And also baby things. Like things upmaid into babies. I know, right?
喜欢我的，还有珍娜的。哦，他给你做一个。快看他。尤达宝宝。哦，天哪。它还有一个小婴儿床，是手工钩织的。看，它是一个圣诞装饰品。好吧，你知道我最喜欢的两样东西是圣诞装饰品和手工圣诞物品。你一定得有这个。还有婴儿用品。就像把东西做成婴儿一样。我懂，对吧？
Baby elephant. I was just watching this movie Journey 2 with my son and they have little bitty tiny elephants on the island. The elephants are shrunk down in their little and you're so cute when they're tiny. Well now you have a tiny baby Yoda from Shoe. And that's from Shoe, Jenna.
小象。我刚才正和儿子一起看电影《地心历险记2》，岛上有那种小得不行的微型象。大象在它们的小房子里缩得很小，当它们这么微型时，真是太可爱了。现在你从休那里得到了一个微型尤达宝宝。那是休送的，珍娜。
Oh, Shoe, thank you so much, Angela. Thank you so much. Well, Angela, I have to have one. I have a surprise for you, but I'm gonna save it. Is it a scary movie you're gonna make me see? I got you a severed head from a famous, Halloween story. Famous scary movie.
哦，休，非常感谢你，安吉拉。非常感谢。好吧，安吉拉，我必须得有一个。我为你准备了一个惊喜，但我先留着。你要让我看一部恐怖电影吗？我给你弄到了一个著名万圣节故事里的断头。著名的恐怖电影。
No, I got you Freddy's glove. No, I didn't. This is not a tangible item that I'm gonna hand you, but it is a thing I'm gonna tell you. Okay, I can't wait. Okay, let's start with Fast Fact number one. I declare with full authority. bankruptcy! No. We have reached full Mindy. The carpet is when we reach full Mindy. This is full Mindy you guys. You're gonna hear it. You know it. It's happening. I asked Sam to make a compilation of all of the things that the character of Kelly says
不，我给你弄到了弗莱迪的手套。不，我没有。这不是一个我要递给你的实物，而是一件我要告诉你的事情。好的，我等不及了。好的，我们从快速冷知识第一条开始。我全权宣布。破产！不。我们已经达到了完全的明迪（Mindy）状态。地毯那一集就是我们达到完全明迪状态的时候。大家，这就是完全的明迪。你们会听到的。你们懂的。它正在发生。我让萨姆把凯莉这个角色在附楼里对吉姆说的
to Jim back in the annex to prove that we have hit full Mindy. So first of all, the hair is transformed. The hair is pretty much down just a tiny clip, but it's fashionable. The outfit, super pink, fluffy, skirt, all of it. Pink lip stick. She sits on her desk. She puts her feet up. She's like, I mean, come on. She also talks about Beyonce. This is a big thing. She talks about the color pink. She crushes on Ryan and at the end, she breaks.
所有的话剪辑成了一个合集，来证明我们已经完全进入了明迪状态。首先，发型变了。发型基本上是披散着的，只别了一个小发夹，但很时尚。这套衣服，超级粉色，毛茸茸的，裙子，全套。粉色口红。她坐在办公桌上。她把脚翘起来。她就像是，我是说，拜托。她还谈到了碧昂丝。这是一件大事。她谈到了粉色。她迷恋瑞安，最后，她崩溃了。
Here it is in its glory, the full Mindy. Do it. I'm serious, my closet doors will not shut. Beyonce, pink the color, pick the person, hot dogs, basically anything that is awesome. Oh my god, he is so cute. Would you talk to him for me and see if he likes me? Oh please Jim, please, please Jim, please, please, please, he's so cute. I like him so much and I would do it but I'm too shy. Please Jim, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, he's so cute. I like him so much and I would do it, but I'm too shy. Please't worry, we're not done tracking this in case you were worried.
它以最荣耀的姿态展现出来了，完整的明迪。来吧。说真的，我的衣柜门都关不上了。碧昂丝，粉色这个颜色，粉色这个人，热狗，基本上所有棒极了的东西。哦，天哪，他太可爱了。你能帮我跟他说说话，看他喜不喜欢我吗？求你了吉姆，求你了，求你了吉姆，求你了，求你了，求你了，他太可爱了。我太喜欢他了，我本来可以自己去，但我太害羞了。求你了吉姆，求你了，求你了，求你了，求你了，求你了，求你了，求你了，求你了，求你了，他太可爱了。我太喜欢他了，我本来可以自己去，但我太害羞了。别担心，我们还没追踪完这个，以防你们担心。
Oh yeah. I mean, if, you know, next episode she has a bun, we're gonna let you know. I'm pretty sure in Casino Night, she gets extensions. Like suddenly that we never speak of or her character never speaks of, but she's got this gorgeous long hair in Casino Night, so we'll track that as well. All right. FastVac number two, we'll track that as well. All right, fast fact number two, we have a big guest star, Ken Howard shows up as Ed Truck.
哦，对。我的意思是，如果，你知道的，下一集她扎了个丸子头，我们会告诉你的。我很确定在《赌场之夜》那一集里，她接了长发。就像突然出现的、我们从不提起、她的角色也从不提起的东西，但她在《赌场之夜》里有着一头华丽的长发，所以我们也会追踪这个。好啦。快速冷知识第二条，我们也会追踪这个。好啦，快速冷知识第二条，我们有一个重量级客串明星，肯·霍华德（Ken Howard）饰演埃德·特拉克（Ed Truck）。
Now, this is the only episode where we see this character, but we referred him a lot. He was the boss of the office before Michael, and Michael worked under him when he was a salesman. Ken Howard is a famous character actor in Hollywood. First of all, he's six feet, six inches tall. Is that insane? He's so tall.
现在，这是我们看到这个角色的唯一一集，但我们经常提到他。他是迈克尔之前的办公室老板，迈克尔做销售员时就在他手下工作。肯·霍华德是好莱坞著名的性格演员。首先，他身高六英尺六英寸（约1.98米）。这不疯狂吗？他太高了。
You notice in the scene that he does with Steve, that he's like kind of towering over Steve. He's a very large person. So Ken played basketball in school and he was offered a number of scholarships, but he turned them all down in favor of pursuing an acting career. And he started his career in the theater, Angela. A theater actor. Why? I studied theater classes too, Jenna.
你注意到他在和史蒂夫演对手戏时，他简直像是在史蒂夫头顶上俯视。他是个身材非常高大的人。所以肯在学校时打过篮球，并获得过好几个奖学金，但他为了追求演艺事业把它们都拒绝了。而且他的职业生涯是从剧院开始的，安吉拉。剧院演员。为什么？我也学过戏剧课，珍娜。
You're like, Angela, it's this thing called theater. Theater actor? I mean, you know, I'm kind of a fancy theater person. Well, you know, I didn't meet Ken or she was seen with him, but I'll be a taband was felt. Did you study like dialects and you're acting theater school? I see what you're doing there. Oh, do you know what? I see what you're doing. You're digging.
你就像在说，安吉拉，有个东西叫戏剧。剧院演员？我的意思是，你知道的，我算是个高级戏剧迷。好吧，你知道的，我没见过肯或者跟他一起被看到，但那种感觉确实存在。你在戏剧学校学过方言和表演吗？我懂你在干嘛了。哦，你知道吗？我懂你在干嘛了。你在挖苦。
All right. Well, he won a Tony award. He appeared in over 100 movies and television series during his 47-year career. He appeared in over a hundred movies and television series during his 47 year career Unfortunately, Ken passed away in 2016, but he left behind this huge legacy You know, he was even the president of the screen actor's guild union for four years. Yes, so he is guys Justa and icon of the entertainment industry and we were so lucky to have him for just this one scene. Oh, it was huge. We were thrilled, thrilled. So, Angela, fast fact number three is my surprise to you. Oh, okay.
好吧，他获得过托尼奖。在他47年的职业生涯中，他出演了100多部电影和电视剧。在他47年的职业生涯中，他出演了100多部电影和电视剧。不幸的是，肯于2016年去世了，但他留下了巨大的遗产。你知道，他甚至还担任过美国演员工会的主席四年。是的，所以大家看，他绝对是娱乐界的一代偶像，我们非常幸运能让他客串仅仅这一个镜头。哦，太棒了。我们激动坏了，激动坏了。那么，安吉拉，快速冷知识第三条是我给你的惊喜。哦，好吧。
Are you ready for it? I don't know. I watched Game of Thrones. What? What? That's right. What episode? The first two and a half episodes.
你准备好了吗？我不知道。我看了《权力的游戏》。什么？什么？没错。哪一集？前两集半。
Did you really? Yeah, I couldn't turn it off. Do you like it? I have a lot of thoughts. Oh, no. Do you want my thoughts? Yes. Okay So first of all episode one of Game of Thrones. Okay. Very horror movie, Angela. The white walkers and the dismembered bodies and love that. I know I was like why didn't she tell me about this part that I'm in? I thought you knew about the white walkers. Jenna, we called my cat Otter the white walker. I didn't know what that meant.
你真的看了？对啊，我根本停不下来。你喜欢吗？我有好多感想。哦，不。你想听我的感想吗？想。好的。所以首先，《权力的游戏》第一集。好的。太像恐怖电影了，安吉拉。异鬼、肢解的尸体，我太喜欢了。我知道，当时我就想，为什么她不告诉我这部分我也会参与？我以为你知道异鬼的事呢。珍娜，我们管我的猫“水獭”叫异鬼。我不知道那是什么意思。
I don't know what that means. It's because he was so old. He was like 22 years old. And he barely had any fur left. And he'd be like, and we call him the white walker. Well, I liked the opening. Then we cut to the credit walker. Well, I liked the opening. Then we cut to the credit sequence,
我不知道那是什么意思。那是因为它太老了。它当时大概22岁了。它身上几乎没有毛了。它会发出那种声音，我们就叫它异鬼。好吧，我喜欢开场。然后切到片头字幕。好吧，我喜欢开场。然后切到片头字幕，
which is going over this map of Lanes and names of Lanes. And I was just like, oh, this is the part I don't want to learn. Okay, that part is long and just get past it. And also, as seasons change and the topography changes, those images change. But anyway, just skip over it. Then I want to say there's a lot of brother sister love. Listen, in the beginning, just a lot.
就是展示这幅大陆地图和大陆名称的那个。当时我就想，哦，这是我不想学的部分。好吧，那部分很长，直接跳过就行了。而且，随着季节变换和地形改变，那些图像也会变。不管怎样，直接跳过它。然后我想说，里面有好多兄妹之爱。听着，在一开始，真的有好多。
In the beginning, and then I think that kind of tape was off a little bit. Okay. I know. Listen, there's some messed up stuff. Okay. Well, I'm liking the, is it the Stark family? Yes. Lord Stark. Yes. And his family. I'm digging on them. Oh, okay. I'm hating the queen and her brother. Oh, yeah. I know.
在一开始，然后我觉得那种情节后来稍微收敛了一点。我知道。听着，有些情节挺乱七八糟的。好吧。不过我挺喜欢那个，是叫史塔克家族吗？对。史塔克大人。对。还有他的家人。我挺喜欢他们的。哦，好吧。我讨厌那个王后和她的弟弟。哦，对。我知道。
Ooh, the Lannisters. Ooh, the Lannisters. Is that their name? Okay. But here's my big observation. Okay. And I want you to help me out here. This is fantasy, right? This is not based on anything. No, it's fantasy. Game of Thrones is just fantasy. Yeah. Okay. Here's my beef. Okay, you're only two episodes in. Go on. Two and a half. Here's my beef. That's why I want you to speak to this for me. Okay. Why can't the women do more than so in Mary?
哦，兰尼斯特家族。哦，兰尼斯特家族。那是他们的名字吗？好吧。但这是我的重大观察。好的。我需要你帮我解答一下。这是奇幻作品，对吧？这不是根据什么真实历史改编的吧？不，这是奇幻。权力的游戏纯粹是奇幻。对。好吧。我的疑问来了。好吧，你才看了两集半。继续。两集半。我的疑问来了。这就是为什么我想让你帮我解答一下。好的。为什么女人们除了做针线活和嫁人之外就不能干点别的？
Oh, they do. They're going to do a lot more. I'm just saying that you take the Wonder Woman thing, right? And it's fantasy. And so it's about like a badass island of women warriors. Because we can make up anything we want. It's not based in any real time period. So why does fantasy, as a genre in general, seem to put men and women in such traditional roles?
哦，她们能。她们后面会做很多很多事。我只是说，你拿《神奇女侠》来举例吧，对吧？这是奇幻作品。所以它是关于一个由女性女战士组成的不羁岛屿的故事。因为我们可以凭空捏造任何我们想要的东西。它不是基于任何真实的时期。所以为什么奇幻作品作为一种整体流派，似乎总是把男人和女性放在如此传统的角色中？
Basically, especially for Game of Thrones, I mean, you guys out there that have watched it now, this is kind of a little bit of a subtle hint, but she's not gonna get it, so just ignore, ignore. The women pretty much end up burning it all to the crowd. They are literally like, I am what I am! They serve it up, lady, don't you worry. All right. They're gonna dish it out.
基本上，特别是对于《权力的游戏》来说，我的意思是，你们这些现在已经看过的人，这其实算是一个小小的微妙暗示，但她不会懂的，所以忽略，忽略。女人们到最后几乎把一切都烧成平地。她们简直就像是在说，我就是我！她们会把这股狠劲端上来的，女士，你不用担心。好吧。她们会狠狠回击的。
I really hope that that girl, the girl who loves the sword play And that's a career. Okay, let me trust me. Okay, all right. Ari is gonna do. Are he's gonna be okay? Ari has a list. I'm not even gonna get into it. Oh wait, whoa wait, wait, wait. She has a list. You don't want to be on her list. You know, I love a list Honey, you don't want to be on this list. Ooh, okay. I can't wait for Ari's list. Oh, it's good. Okay. I want to say one last thing, and we can cut this out if this goes on too long.
我真的希望那个女孩，那个喜欢玩剑的女孩……这也是一种职业。好吧，相信我。好吧，艾莉亚会怎么做。艾莉亚会没事的？艾莉亚有个名单。我甚至都不想细说了。哦，等等，哇，等等，等等，等等。她有一个名单。你可不想上她的名单。你知道的，我最喜欢列名单了。亲爱的，你绝对不想上这个名单。哦，好吧。我等不及看艾莉亚的名单了。哦，那可太棒了。好吧。我最后说一件事，如果这部分太长的话我们可以把它剪掉。
I want to just say one last thing. Winter is coming. We get it. It's coming, guys. We've been talking, I mean, how many times per episode do they need to say winter is coming in? Also, this winter, it's like, I feel like they have the wrong name for it. It doesn't sound like a winter is coming.
我只想说最后一件事。凛冬将至。我们知道了。它要来了，各位。我们一直在讨论，我的意思是，每集里他们需要说多少次“凛冬将至”啊？而且，这个冬天，我觉得他们给它起错名字了。听起来不像是冬天要来了。
It sounds like an avalanche is coming to bury you for seven years. It's cold. It's an avalanche of dead walking people, okay? They're coming. That's what's coming. The white walkers are coming. So the white walkers come with winter,
听起来像是一场雪崩要来把你们埋上七年。太冷了。这是一场行尸走肉的雪崩，好吧？它们正在靠近。这就是要来的东西。异鬼要来了。所以异鬼随着冬天一起到来，
but the white walkers aren't affected by winter Jenna, I'm not gonna get into it. I'm not gonna get into it. It's all I'm saying is winter is coming is a layered Metaphor, okay, I get a cold. Oh, okay, okay All right, well good and the dog's but is that my saying it right the dog's rock Rockies, yeah. And Carl Drago. Yeah. Is this name Carl? No, it's Carl. Oh, Carl. I love that you thought that the guy that speaks no English
但异鬼却不受冬天的影响。珍娜，我不想深入讨论这个。我不想深入讨论这个。我只想说，“凛冬将至”是一个多层隐喻，好吧，我知道天冷。哦，好吧，好吧。好吧，还有那只狗的——我是说，我没说错吧，那只狗的“罗基斯”，对吧？还有卡奥·德戈。对。那个人叫卡尔吗？不，是卡尔。哦，卡尔。我太喜欢你以为那个一句英语都不会说、
and his shirtless on a horse was named Carl. I did. Kaleesi and Carl, they're going to make a happy pair. Look at him riding off in the sunset. Carl, I was like Carl, they all, the only freedom by his first and last name all the time. I have noticed that in two and a half episodes he has only said the word no three times.
半裸着骑在马上的家伙叫卡尔了。我确实这么觉得。丹妮莉丝（卡丽熙）和卡尔，他们会是一对幸福的伴侣。看他骑着马走向夕阳。卡尔，我当时想，卡尔，他们所有人都，大家一直都只用他的名和姓来称呼他。我注意到在两集半的时间里，他只说了三次“不”。
It's because he can't, Carl can't speak English, Jenna. Okay, thank you for watching. Thank you for watching. That was it. Thank you. I gave in, I did it, I watched it, I'm a little bit hooked.
那是因为他不会，卡尔不会说英语，珍娜。好吧，谢谢你们观看。谢谢你们观看。就是这样。谢谢。我妥协了，我看了，我有点入迷了。
Okay, good. You'll love all the white walker stuff. Okay. I now, I guess, have to watch what's at the edge with the edge. With the edge. The edge. Have you never seen the edge? We already know this.
好吧，很好。你会喜欢所有异鬼的剧情的。好吧。我现在猜我得去看看边缘边缘的那部电影了。边缘。边缘。你从来没看过《势不两立》（The Edge）吗？我们早就知道了。
But you've never seen it. How many different ways do you want me to tell you? I haven't seen it. You know about the bear. How do you know about the bear? I've seen trailers. I've seen, you know what? All I needed to see was a man like getting attacked by a bear. And I'm like, I'm out. Also, so the revenue was not for you. Oh, I'm the award-winning film, the Revin.
但你从来没看过。你想让我用多少种不同的方式告诉你？我没看过。你知道那头熊的事。你怎么知道熊的事的？我看过预告片。我看了，你知道吗？我只需要看到一个男人被一头熊袭击，然后我就想，我告辞了。另外，所以《荒野猎人》（The Revenant）也不适合你。哦，我是说那部获奖电影《荒野猎人》。
No, no. Another great survivalist film for all you survivalist. No, I saw it trailer and what's his name? Leo DiCaprio is getting mauled by a bear and like pass hard pass. All right well you know I like quotes from things and I really appreciated this quote from Game of Thrones. I love that we're still talking about it. Go. The man who passes the sentence should swing the sword. Oh yeah. I liked that. And he made his son cut off that guy's head. No, he made him watch as he cut off the head. Oh, yeah. I liked that. And he made his son cut off that guy's head.
不，不。另一部适合所有求生主义者的伟大求生电影。不，我看过它的预告片，然后那个叫什么名字来着？莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥被一头熊疯狂撕咬，我直接——绝对拒绝，拒绝。好吧，你知道我喜欢引用各种名言，我真的很欣赏《权力的游戏》里的这句名言。我很高兴我们还在讨论这个。说吧。判处死刑的人必须亲自动手行刑。哦，对。我喜欢这个。而且他还让他儿子去砍那个家伙的头。不，他是让他看着自己砍下那个头。哦，对。我喜欢这个。而且他还让他儿子去砍那个家伙的头。
No, he made him watch as he cut off the head. Well, eventually he makes him cut off someone's head. Wow. Spoiler alert. A bunch of people are gonna lose their heads. Just, it's part of life back then. Okay, back to him, fantasy land. There you go, guys.
不，他是让他看着自己砍下那个头。好吧，最后他确实让他去砍了某个人的头。哇。剧透警告。一堆人都要掉脑袋了。这就是当时生活的一部分。好吧，回到我们的话题，奇幻世界。就是这样，各位。
That was my fast fact number three. I promise after this break, we will begin talking about the office again, specifically the carpet. We will break down that episode for you. I think Dwight would have loved Game of Thrones. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. I think him and Angelou would have watched it.
那是我的快速冷知识第三条。我向你们保证，在这段广告之后，我们将开始重新谈论《办公室》，特别是地毯那一集。我们将为你们剖析那一集。我觉得德怀特一定会爱死《权力的游戏》。哦，对。哦，对。我觉得他和安吉拉一定会一起看。
You guys would have spoken to one another in Dothraki. Oh, for sure. It would be like our code language. You have a somewhat Dothraki in relationship. A bit of a Cal-Kale code language. You have a somewhat dothrakiin relationship, a bit of a Cal-Kaleese thing. You mean Carl. All right, let's go to break.
你们俩肯定会用多斯拉克语互相交谈。哦，肯定的。那会成为我们的暗语。你们俩有一种类似多拉克人的关系。有点像卡奥和卡丽熙的关系。你是说卡尔。好吧，我们进广告。
Okay, we're back from break. We start this episode with a cold open. Pam is on vacation. Yes. Ryan is at the reception desk and Jim keeps glancing up. At Ryan and he's like, what are you looking at? And Ryan has that great talking head where he's like, Jim keeps looking over reception.
好的，我们广告回来了。这一集一开场就是一段片头搞笑短剧（cold open）。帕姆在度假。是的。瑞安坐在前台，吉姆一直抬眼看瑞安，然后瑞安就问他在看什么。瑞安有一个很棒的面对镜头独白（talking head），他说吉姆一直看着前台。
But it's not as creepy as the way Michael's looking at him. Yes, exactly. Okay, so the episode starts and Pam is back from vacation. She's happy, she's at front reception, Michael Waxen and calls her spamster. Yeah, he hasn't done this bit in a while where he takes her name and smashes it with other things. And she's like, let me guess how you got that Pam spam
但这并没有迈克尔看他的眼神那么让人毛骨悚然。是的，没错。好吧，所以剧集开始了，帕姆度假回来了。她很开心，坐在前台，迈克尔走过来叫她“帕姆斯特”（Pamster）。对，他好久没玩这种把她的名字和其他词拼在一起的梗了。然后她说，让我猜猜你是怎么组合出这个词的：帕姆、罐头肉（spam）
and hamster, spamster. And then as he walks off, he goes, I am Pam, it's Bacoli. You guys, for your young people, he's pretending to be Jeff Spacoli from Fast Times at Richmont High. Yeah, that's Bacoli. You guys, for your young people, he's pretending to be Jeff Bacoli from Fast Times at Richmont High. Yeah, that's a dated reference. That is a dated reference.
和仓鼠（hamster），帕姆斯特（pamster）。然后他走开时说，“我是帕姆，这是巴科利（Spicoli）”。各位，对于你们年轻人来说，他这是在假装扮演《开放的美国学府》（Fast Times at Ridgemont High）里的杰夫·巴科利。对，那是巴科利。各位，对于你们年轻人来说，他这是在假装扮演《开放的美国学府》里的杰夫·巴科利。对，这是一个很有年代感的梗。这是一个很有年代感的梗。
Michael goes in his office, what happens, Jenna? There's something very smelly on the carpet in his office. What I love about this is we don't ever show you too much of it. You see a little bit on the carpet, though, and what you see is foul. Yeah, it is so gross. It's pretty awful. And he makes a bunch of people come into the office
迈克尔走进他的办公室，发生了什么，珍娜？他办公室的地毯上有某种非常臭的东西。我喜欢这一点的是，我们从未向你们过多展示它。不过你在地毯上看到了那么一点点，而且你看到的东西非常恶心。是的，太恶心了。简直糟透了。他叫了许多人进办公室
to see what it is. We had a fan question from David Griffiths and Haley Crook and many others. They wanted to know, was there anything in the office that made it actually smell so that we were having authentic reactions. No. That is just some good act in right there. Real good acting as I watched this, I was so impressed.
来看看那是什么。我们收到了来自大卫·格里菲斯（David Griffiths）、海莉·克鲁克（Haley Crook）以及许多其他人的粉丝提问。他们想知道，办公室里真的有什么东西散发出那么臭的味道，以至于我们的反应都是真实的吗？没有。那纯粹是精湛的演技。真正的精湛演技，我在看这一段时，印象太深刻了。
I was so impressed. I actually texted Brian and I was like, I want you to go back and rewatch the carpet. When you get a whiff of whatever it is, it made me laugh so hard. I was like, he did such a great job. And Michael has a line, you guys, I feel like it's sort of my vernacular, like the way I would talk, he says, there is a stink in there.
我印象太深刻了。我甚至给布莱恩发了信息，我说，我想让你回去重新看一遍地毯那一集。当你闻到那种东西的味道时，真的把我逗笑了。我说，他演得太棒了。迈克尔有一句台词，大家，我觉得这有点符合我的说话习惯，就像我平时说话的方式一样，他说：“里面有一股臭味（stink）。”
That is how you would describe it. Oh, there's a stink, y'all. And I love Creed's line. A lot of fans pointed this out, someone making soup, somebody making soup. So my sister Janet was visiting and watched this episode with me. She made me screen grab Villas' face reaction to when Creed says somebody making soup.
这就是你会用来形容它的词。哦，里面有一股臭味，大家。我喜欢克里德的台词。很多粉丝都指出了这一点：“有人在做汤吗，有人在做汤。”所以我的姐姐珍妮来拜访我时和我一起看了这一集。她让我截下了菲利斯（Phyllis）听到克里德说“有人在做汤”时的面部表情。
Seriously, it is hilarious. It's at three minutes, 10 seconds. Somebody making soup, look at Villas' face. Next, we have Michael's talking head where he's talking about fear factor Michael's talking head where he's talking about fear factor and he has to leave. And then for the rest of the episode, we're clearing out his office. I did a deep dive on fear factor. Why, Jenna? Why did I do a deep dive? I don't know. This has started to happen to us where something's mentioned to an episode and then we spend
说真的，太搞笑了。就在3分10秒的时候。有人在做汤，看菲利斯脸上的表情。接下来，是迈克尔的面对镜头独白，他在谈论《惊恐夺标》迈克尔的面对镜头独白，他在谈论《惊恐夺标》，然后他不得不离开。然后在这集的剩余时间里，我们都在清理他的办公室。我深入研究了《惊恐夺标》。为什么，珍娜？我为什么要深入研究这个？我不知道。我们现在开始出现这种情况，只要剧集里提到某个东西，我们就会花
hours watching clips or researching things on websites. Oh my gosh. It was like you watching all the videos of the Hooters' birthdays. Yeah. I watched these fear factor clips. You guys, it was like, okay, eat this dried horse rectum. I'm not kidding. Yeah.
几个小时看剪辑视频或者在网站上查资料。哦，天哪。这就像你看那些全美猫头鹰餐厅（Hooters）生日派对的视频一样。没错。我看了这些《惊恐夺标》的剪辑。大家，那感觉就像是，好吧，吃掉这个风干的马直肠。我没开玩笑。是的。
I'm not kidding or intestine or something. And then I looked up why it got canceled. Okay. It's so gross. What happened? I don't even think we can see it here. What happened? They have.
我没开玩笑，或者是马的肠子什么的。然后我查了它为什么被取消。好吧。太恶心了。发生了什么？我觉得我们甚至都不能在这里播。发生了什么？他们有。
It got canceled because of an incident? Yes, and they didn't err it. But it's why it got canceled and Joe Rogan is talked about it. It's so gross. What? Okay, you had two choices. This episode is called the He-Ha episode. You could drink donkey pee or donkey semen.
它是因为一次事故而被取消的吗？是的，而且他们没有播出。但这正是它被取消的原因，乔·罗根（Joe Rogan）也谈过这件事。太恶心了。什么？好吧，你有两个选择。这一集被称为“驴尿”集。你可以喝驴尿或者驴精液。
That is horrible, Jenna. That is horrible Jenna. That is horrible. Did they do it? They did it. Oh! They did it. And one guy said, as he started drinking, he bombeted back in his own cup.
太可怕了，珍娜。这太可怕了，珍娜。太可怕了。他们喝了吗？他们喝了。哦！他们喝了。其中一个家伙说，他刚开始喝，就把东西又吐回了自己的杯子里。
Oh God. It's horrible. Oh my God. It's horrible. And how did this get, I mean, who was like, yeah, that's a great idea That's also how did they get the donkey just oh Sorry is my first thought
天哪。太可怕了。哦，天哪。太可怕了。这到底是怎么想出来的，我是说，是谁想出这种“对，这真是个好主意”的？还有，他们是怎么弄到这头驴的，哦，抱歉，这是我的第一反应。
Whose job was that wow No no no no no no no no not happening um I don't think so. No, not happening. Um, next up in the episode, wow, sorry, did everyone do it? Or just like what happens if you don't do it your out? I don't know, like I know they're, you know, there's the contest and if you do it, ultimately whatever all the challenges are, I don't know how people get picked, but whoever does the challenge, if they don't do it, they're out.
那是谁的工作，哇。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不可能，呃，我觉得不会。不，不可能，呃，接下来在这一集里，哇，抱歉，是不是每个人都必须完成？还是说，如果你不做会怎么样，是不是不吃就被淘汰了？我不知道，我知道他们有，你知道的，比赛，如果你照做了，最终不管是什么挑战，我不知道大家是怎么被选中的，但无论是谁面临挑战，如果不做，就会被淘汰。
It is a crazy show. Crazy. All right. I am looking in the booth where Sam and Cody are sitting at everyone. They seem sad. I have ruined their tape. You guys, I just, well, like this was such a big deal for Michael to like be like, this is my fear factor audition tape. I was like, oh, yeah, what was that show again? I just started looking it up. That was like one of the first things that came up. Anyway, you're welcome. Where are we? So next up, Jim enters. He asks about Pam's vacation. He is so excited that she's back at the reception desk, but then we reveal that Roy and Darryl are also upstairs and that Roy is, they're cleaning out Michael's office,
这真是一个疯狂的节目。疯狂。好吧。我正在看萨姆和科迪坐着的控制室里的每个人。他们看起来很难过。我把他们的磁带毁了。大家，我只是——好吧，因为迈克尔表现得好像“这是我的《惊恐夺标》试镜录像带”是一件大事，当时我就想，哦，对，那个节目叫什么来着？我刚开始查了一下。那是跳出来的第一批结果之一。不管怎样，不用谢。我们讲到哪了？所以接下来，吉姆进来了。他问起帕姆的度假。他看到帕姆回到前台工作显得超级兴奋，但接着我们发现罗伊和达里尔也在楼上，罗伊正在——他们正在清理迈克尔的办公室，
they're gonna replace the carpet, basically. And Pam and Roy are clearly on good terms. They're like giggly. They're giggly and Roy is like engaging with her. You know what I mean? She looks over and mouth the word help, you know, because he's gotta go do this gross job and she laughs. And so they're being kind of flirty and sweet
他们基本上要换掉地毯。而且帕姆和罗伊显然关系很好。他们一直在咯咯笑。他们在傻笑，罗伊也在跟她互动。你知道我的意思吗？她转过头去，用嘴型说了句“救命”（因为罗伊得去做这个恶心的工作），然后她笑了。所以他们显得有点调情、很甜蜜，
and Jim clocks it right away. We had a fan question from Jamie Boggs. Why on earth are the warehouse guys changing the carpet? How is that in their job description? I kind of agree, but it makes sense to me. I feel like Michael makes people do things outside of their job description all the time. And so we kind of had to do this too,
吉姆一下子就注意到了。我们收到了来自杰米·博格斯（Jamie Boggs）的粉丝提问。为什么仓库的伙计们要换地毯？这怎么会在他们的工作职责范围内？我有点赞同，但对我来说这也说得通。我觉得迈克尔总是让大家做一些超出他们工作职责范围的事。所以我们某种程度上也必须这么做，
just as a writing convention, we needed a reason for Roy to be upstairs for this whole episode. So we kind of need him to change the carpet. But a lot of people asked, did they really rip up and replace the carpet? Well, they did really rip it up. But I don't think they really replaced it.
这只是一种剧作常规，我们需要一个理由让罗伊在这一整集里都待在楼上。所以我们某种程度上需要他来换地毯。但很多人问，他们真的把地毯撕掉并换新的了吗？好吧，他们确实真的把它撕掉了。但我不认为他们真的换了新的。
I think they just put it back down again in the end. Yeah, I think there was like a top carpet they pulled up. Yeah. But then they, yeah, it's not quite. So, but they did. I mean, they really did dismantle the office in the middle of this shooting. Yes. And all of Michael's talking heads take place in the conference room.
我觉得他们最后只是把它又铺回去了。对，我觉得他们掀起了一层顶层的地毯。对。但后来他们，对，也不完全是。不过他们确实——我是说，他们在拍摄过程中真的把办公室给拆了。是的。而且迈克尔的所有面对镜头独白都是在会议室里进行的。
All of the stuff is piled behind them. Yes. So that's sort of a new spot where we see Michael. That was a fan question too from Alexandra. What is the room Michael has his talking heads in while his carpet is being cleaned? It's the conference room. I was curious too, and so I zoomed in on the scene where Michael is talking and I realized it Was the conference room because the painting is hanging on the wall behind him. Yeah, it was the painting That was always in the conference room
所有的东西都堆在他身后。是的。所以那是我们看到迈克尔的一个新地点。这也是亚历山大（Alexandra）提出的粉丝问题。地毯正在清理时，迈克尔进行面对镜头独白的那个房间是什么地方？那是会议室。我也很好奇，所以我把迈克尔说话的那个镜头放大看了看，然后我意识到那是会议室，因为他身后的墙上挂着那幅画。对，那是那幅
I felt like that was a nice little touch to let the audience know where he was at one point it actually falls down I noticed that banging around that was a blooper. That was a blooper. That was not intended. But it was a great, just like, kind of reminder, like where he was. So next up, Michael takes over Jim's desk, forcing Jim into the annex. He's going to sit next to Kelly. She explains that Toby used to sit there, but he had to move due to an allergy. To the desk.
一直挂在会议室里的画。我觉得这是一个很好的小细节，能让观众知道他在哪里。有一幕它甚至掉下来了，我注意到有咣当的声音，那是个失误。那是个失误。本来不是故意的。但那是一个很棒的、类似于提醒观众他在哪里的设计。所以接下来，迈克尔占用了吉姆的办公桌，迫使吉姆去了附楼。他要坐在凯莉旁边。她解释说托比以前坐在那里，但他因为过敏不得不搬走。对桌子过敏。
To the desk. His allergy was to the desk. I'm desk. And his allergy was to the desk. I'm pretty sure all those desks are the same desk, but Toby just had a specific allergy to that one. So then we have Michael in the bullpen, and he's chatting with Dwight. They're kind of talking about the old days. They start talking about Ed Truck,
对办公桌。他对办公桌过敏。我很确定所有这些办公桌都是同一款桌子，但托比偏偏对那一张桌子产生了特定的过敏。然后我们在大办公室（bullpen）看到了迈克尔，他正在和德怀特闲聊。他们聊起了过去的好日子。他们开始谈论埃德·特拉克，
and you see that great flashback photo. And the mullet haircut. Yeah. Also, at five minutes 12 seconds, Dwight is so happy that Michael is gonna be sitting next to him. He is just so thrilled. And I watched the deleted scenes for this episode and there's a really cute talking head where Dwight is like, this is just a gift and the woman I'm dating might say it's a gift from God, but I don't know about that. And it flashed. It cuts to me, but there are some great deleted scenes for this episode. If you have the DVDs and I have a talking head, Kevin has a really funny one.
然后你看到了那张很棒的闪回照片。还有那个鲻鱼头造型（mullet）。是的，还有，在5分12秒的时候，德怀特看到迈克尔要坐在他旁边，开心极了。他简直兴奋疯了。我看了这一集的被删减片段，里面有一个非常可爱的面对镜头独白，德怀特说：“这简直是一个天赐的礼物，我约会的那个女人可能会说这是上帝的恩赐，但我可不确定。”然后画面切到了我。不过这一集确实有很多很棒的被删减片段。如果你有DVD的话，我有面对镜头独白，凯文也有一个非常搞笑的独白。
There's a deleted scene you guys where Jim is looking up the hotel where Pam and Roy stayed in the Poconos. Oh, and Kelly. That's a little depressing. I know. And Kelly's like, what are you looking at? There's also a deleted scene where he's eating alone in his car. Oh, yeah, because he can't find anywhere to eat. Exactly. Exactly. But there is some really sweet, sort of Dwight Angelo little nods to that relationship in the deleted scenes. And also during this whole sort of Dwight Michael moment, we learn that Dwight is sitting
大家，有一个被删减片段是吉姆在查帕姆和罗伊在波科诺斯山住的那家酒店。哦，还有凯莉。这有点让人沮丧。我懂。凯莉问：“你在看什么？”还有一个被删减片段是他独自在车里吃东西。哦，对，因为他找不到地方吃午饭。没错了。没错了。但在被删减片段中，确实有一些德怀特和安吉拉之间非常甜蜜、针对他们关系的微小点头致意。而且在德怀特和迈克尔的这段谈话期间，我们得知德怀特正坐在
where Todd Packer used to sit. And Michael is sitting in his old desk, his ed truck would have been in his office. So Michael is having a little bit of like reliving the glory days of when he was out on the floor as salesman. Yes. I think we have some real Stanley sass. Ooh.
以前托德·帕克（Todd Packer）坐过的位置上。而迈克尔坐在他自己的旧办公桌上，埃德·特拉克以前会在他的办公室里。所以迈克尔有点像在重温当他还是外场销售员时的辉煌岁月。是的。我觉得我们看到了一点真正的斯坦利式毒舌（Stanley sass）。哦。
Oh, Stanley sass. Yes. At seven minutes, one second, Michael bugs Stanley and Stanley is on the phone and this is what. This is what Stanley says to him. I just loved it. Leslie David Baker did such an amazing job. What is it that you need right now
哦，斯坦利式毒舌。是的。在7分1秒的时候，迈克尔烦斯坦利，而斯坦利正在打电话，这就是——这就是斯坦利对他说的话。我太喜欢了。莱斯利·大卫·贝克（Leslie David Baker）演得太棒了。你现在有什么事
that can't wait until I'm off the phone with a customer? I was like, there's some Stanley says. So Michael is now walking around the bullpen and he's just really misbehaving. Yeah, he's like acting out in some way. He thinks maybe they were all in on it, but yet also I think he's trying to live his glory days. He just punches the heck out of Creed.
是不能等我打完这个客户电话再说的？当时我就想，斯坦利式毒舌来了。所以迈克尔现在正在大办公室里转悠，而且他真的很不守规矩。是的，他某种程度上有点行为失控。他觉得可能大家都在合伙整他，但同时我也觉得他是在努力重温昔日的辉煌岁月。他狠狠地给了克里德一拳。
Oh, I loved Creed's reaction to that though. It was so earnest. It's like one of the few times he's truly earnest. He's like, out, why'd you hit me, Michael? Like it actually really hurt him. And Michael as he punched him, yelled, Charlie Horse. He's like a kid on a playground. Basically, he's like a bad kid on a playground, but that's not a Charlie horse. Punching someone isn't a Charlie horse. You know what a Charlie horse is. That's just when your muscle sees his up.
哦，不过我喜欢克里德对此的反应。太真诚了。这是他少有的几次表现得极其真诚。他说：“哎哟，你打我干嘛，迈克尔？”就好像那一拳真的伤到他了。迈克尔在打完他之后，大喊了一声：“马腿抽筋（Charlie Horse）！”他就像操场上的一个小孩。基本上，他就像操场上一个惹事生非的坏小孩，但那根本不是马腿抽筋。打别人一拳才不是马腿抽筋。你知道什么是马腿抽筋。那只是你的肌肉痉挛了。
Well, yeah, but I think what he's trying to say is like, how does a horse bite a apple? Wait, what? Stop. Stop the podcast. What? How is a horse bite a apple? Wait, what? Stop, stop the podcast, what? How's a horse bite an apple? Is that, like, Charlie Horse just hitting someone, or is he hitting someone to give him a Charlie Horse? What is how's a horse bite an apple? Come over here, I'll show you.
好吧，是的，但我认为他想表达的是，马是怎么咬苹果的？等等，什么？停下。停下播客。什么？马是怎么咬苹果的？等等，什么？停，停下播客，什么？马是怎么咬苹果的？这是，就像“马腿抽筋”只是打某人一下，还是他打某人是为了让他马腿抽筋？“马是怎么咬苹果的”到底是什么？过来，我给你示范一下。
No, no, no, no, explain. What is this? This is the thing. I'm not saying you do, though, a person on a playground is called how's a horse bite an apple? Yeah, how's a horse bite an apple? I'm gonna show you. I'm scared. What are you reaching for right now? I'm gonna show you. I'm scared.
不，不，不，不，解释一下。这是什么？就是这个。我不是说你在操场上对别人这么做，这叫“马是怎么咬苹果的？”对，马是怎么咬苹果的？我要给你示范一下。我好害怕。你现在伸手在抓什么？我要给你示范一下。我好害怕。
What are you reaching for right now? You're reaching for what? I'm not. I'm not. What are you reaching for? It's not gonna hurt that bad. If Josh did it to you, he is strong. Okay, what am I doing?
你现在伸手在抓什么？你抓的是什么？我没有。我才没有。你在抓什么？又不会疼得那么厉害。如果乔希对你这么做，他力气可大了。好吧，我正在做什么？
What am I handing you? You got a slide over here. Slide over to what? My cheer. Why? What are you touching? Okay, back up. What?
我递给你的是什么？你得挪过来。挪到哪去？我的椅子。为什么？你在摸什么？好吧，退后。什么？
What are you doing? Look at how I heard that bad. How's a horse bite an up. What? What are you doing? I'm not gonna hurt that bad. How's a horse bite helpful? What? Oh, that thing where you just like squeeze someone's knee. The top of their knee and that two little spots that really hurt. I don't think that hurts. I think that's tickly.
你在干嘛？看我怎么弄得那么疼。马是怎么咬苹果的。什么？你在干嘛？又不会疼得那么厉害。马是怎么咬苹果的？什么？哦，就是那种你捏一下别人的膝盖的动作。膝盖上方有那么两个非常疼的小点。我觉得那不疼。我觉得那是痒痒的。
That's how horse bites an apple. Am I right, Sam? I've never heard how's a horse bite an apple. What? It's going on, St is going on St. Louis? St. Louis. St. Louis, back up. Where I was raised.
那就是马咬苹果的方式。我说的对吧，萨姆？我从来没听过什么“马是怎么咬苹果的”。什么？这是圣路易斯那边的说法吗？圣路易斯。圣路易斯，往后退。我长大的地方。
Do we have horses that bite the apple? This one, come on. I don't know how to react to it. Sam seems to have heard this. Yeah, that made a Twitter who's Concent. Wisconsin has how's a horse bite an apple. Cody, where are you from? Have you heard it? I'm from here
难道我们那儿有会咬苹果的马吗？这个，拜托。我都不知道该怎么反应了。萨姆好像听说过这个。对，这在推特上引起了……威斯康星州有人知道“马是怎么咬苹果的”。科迪，你从哪来的？你听说过吗？我是本地人，
But my grandma was from Kansas and my grandpa's from Tennessee and I've never heard that. Thank you Okay, so Missouri, Kansas and Tennessee. We don't know this horse bites an apple business. Well Texas is Consisting based on a poll of four people We've declared things about major regions of the United States based on a four person poll. That seems to, I think that's kind of how polling is done though. Oh, let's not go there. Okay.
但我奶奶来自堪萨斯州，我爷爷来自田纳西州，我从来没听说过这个。谢谢。好吧，所以密苏里州、堪萨斯州和田纳西州都不知道这个关于马咬苹果的鬼把戏。好吧，德州是根据四个人的民意测验得出的结论。我们根据一个四人测验就对美国的主要地区做出了定论。这似乎——我觉得这差不多就是民意测验的运作方式吧。哦，我们别扯这个了。好吧。
Well, Charlie Horse is just when your muscle sees us up. I know that, but I kind of felt like it was like one of those things where Michael gets it a little wrong. Like, he's like Charlie Horse, but I was like, oh, did he mean how's a horse by the napal? But probably not because that's too many words. And he had to cross the whole room really quickly. Well, Michael also gets Dwight to go over to accounting
好吧，“马腿抽筋”只是指你的肌肉痉挛了。我知道，但我当时觉得这有点像那种迈克尔搞错了一点点的梗。就像，他喊了“马腿抽筋”，但我觉得，哦，他是不是想说“马是怎么咬苹果的？”但大概不是，因为那词太多了。而且他必须非常快地穿过整个房间。好吧，迈克尔还让德怀特去会计部，
and dump their stuff all over the ground. We had a fan question from Alan three. How many times did Stephen Reign mess up the accounting area? Did they do it randomly or was it choreographed? Angela, can you give us some insight? We did it a few times and you know, so every time Michael would say, okay, let's end up accounting. Old-fashioned raid, sales on accounting. They would come over, they'd dump all of our stuff on the floor. I did love that Angela glares it to white, like, don't even. And so he sort of giggles and
把他们的东西全倒在地上。我们收到了来自阿兰三世（Alan Three）的粉丝提问。史蒂夫和雷恩把会计区弄乱了多少次？他们是随机乱搞的还是设计好的动作？安吉拉，你能给我们透露一点吗？我们排练了好几次，你知道的，所以每次迈克尔都会说，“好吧，把会计部端了。”老式突袭，对会计部突袭。他们就会跑过来，把我们的东西全都倒在地上。我确实很喜欢安吉拉狠狠地瞪着德怀特，好像在说“少来这套”。所以他有点傻笑着，
picks up one pencil and throws it on the floor of mine. But yeah, we did that a few times and they were just really, truly just look like Steve and Rain were having fun because they got to come over and mess with us. And then so after you shoot a scene like that and they mess up the area, they say, cut, did the set decorators come over and reset everything? They do because they want the continuity to match. And you know, obviously we would pick up stuff as well, but sometimes we, we would get in the way, like we would start to pick it up and they'd be like, here, let me set that. Because that is their job to make sure it looks exactly like it did before,
捡起一支铅笔，然后扔到了我的地板上。不过是的，我们那样拍了好几次，而且看起来真的很像是史蒂夫和雷恩在玩得很开心，因为他们可以跑过来捉弄我们。然后拍完这样一场戏、他们把地方弄乱之后，他们喊“咔”，布景道具师会过来把所有东西重新摆好吗？他们会的，因为他们希望连戏（continuity）能对上。而且你知道的，显然我们也会自己捡起一些东西，但有时我们会碍事，比如我们刚开始捡，他们就会说：“来，让我来摆放。”因为那是他们的工作，要确保它看起来和之前一模一样，
and I might not get it right. So I remember sometimes before scenes like this, our script supervisor, Veda, she is the person who was in charge of continuity on the show. advisor Veda, she is the person who was in charge of continuity on the show. She would come over and take a picture of the desk area as a reference point. So they could match it each time. Yes. And then after it got all messed up, then Veda would come over with her computer and she'd be like, okay, so this is exactly where the cup was and this is where this was and everything and they would reset the whole thing to Veda's picture and then mess it up again.
而且我自己可能摆得不对。所以我记得有时候在拍这样的戏之前，我们的场记（script supervisor）维达（Veda），她就是负责剧中连戏工作的人。指导维达，她就是负责剧中连戏工作的人。她会过来给办公桌区域拍张照片作为参考点。这样他们每次都能对上。是的。然后等现场被彻底弄乱之后，维达就会拿着她的电脑过来，然后说：“好吧，所以杯子原本是精确放在这个位置的，这个是放在这里的，诸如此类。”然后他们会根据维达的照片把整个场景重新复原，接着再把它弄乱。
Yes. Veda was amazing and she was so sweet and kind and soft spoken. And sometimes she would just walk up to and be like, um, Angela, and on the second line in the scene, you switched your coffee mug from your left hand to your right hand. I'd be like, oh my God, did I? I didn't even realize, yes. So you have to do that every time now.
是的。维达太棒了，她人超级甜美、亲切，说话轻声细语的。有时候她会直接走到我面前说：“呃，安吉拉，在这一场的第二句台词里，你把咖啡马克杯从左手换到了右手。”我会说：“哦天哪，我这么做了吗？我甚至都没意识到，是的。”所以你现在每次都必须这样做。
Yes, I remember that. I remember that at I remember that. At eight minutes, 55 seconds, I'm calling this the fan catch of the day. What is it? It is by Biro. If you freeze and zoom in on Angela's computer, you can see a post-it note that says, quote,
是的，我记得。我记得那——我记得那。在8分55秒的时候，我把这称为“今日最佳粉丝捕捉”。是什么？是比罗（Biro）发现的。如果你暂停并放大安吉拉的电脑屏幕，你可以看到一张便签，上面写着，原话是：
Angela, can I have $5 petty cash to buy some more jelly beans? I'll give you back any change. Thanks. Pam. Catch up the day. That is fantastic. I love that. I love that.
“安吉拉，我能借5美元零用钱去买点更多的果冻豆吗？我会把找零还给你的。谢谢。帕姆。”今日最佳捕捉。太棒了。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。
I think I really wrote that post it note. You probably did. You probably passed it to me in the background because we were bored. And I stuck it there. So then Michael has a talking head about former manager Ed truck and this has one of my favorite Michael quotes. I told myself if I was ever manager, people would laugh when they saw me coming and applaud when I walked away. Mission accomplished. Yeah, way to go. I just want to call out one scene you guys. It's,
我觉得那张便签真的是我写的。你可能真的写了。你可能在背景里把它传给我了，因为我们当时很无聊。然后我把它贴在那儿了。接下来迈克尔有一段面对镜头独白，谈到了前经理埃德·特拉克，这里面有我最喜欢的迈克尔名言之一。我告诉自己，如果我当上经理，当我走来时人们会笑，当我走开时人们会鼓掌。任务达成。是的，干得漂亮。我只想指出一个场景，大家。那是，
I know we're jumping around a little, but it's one I absolutely love at nine minutes, 55 seconds. It made me laugh so hard when Dwight is trying to be the hundred seventh caller. Yes! To win a DVD box set of Jess Roe Tall. Yes! From Rock 107 and he just keeps calling and Michael's paying the expression.
我知道我们有点跳跃，但这是我绝对大爱的一个场景，在9分55秒。当德怀特试图成为第107位打进电话的听众时，把我逗得前仰后合。耶！来赢取杰夫·罗托（Jethro Tull）的CD盒装合集！耶！从107摇滚电台（Rock 107）赢取，他一直在不停地打电话，迈克尔的那个表情。
And then Dwight trying to sneak the call. Just all of it just cracked me up. One of the fun dynamics about the Michael then Dwight trying to sneak the call. Just all of it just cracked me up. One of the fun dynamics about the Michael and Dwight relationship is that it gives Steve an opportunity to play the straight man. Yeah. And he's a very funny straight man. And so a lot of times he's the funny guy and the rest of us are the straight man to Steve, but I love this dynamic shift that happens with Michael and Dwight scenes. I do too. I want you to know I did a little bit of a deep dive for Rock 107.
还有德怀特试图偷偷打电话。所有这一切都让我笑死。迈克尔和德怀特之间有趣的互动动态之一，就是它给了史蒂夫一个扮演“直人”（straight man，喜剧中负责严肃正经以衬托搞笑的人）的机会。是的。而且他是个非常搞笑的直人。所以很多时候他是搞笑的那个人，而我们其他人则是配合史蒂夫的直人，但我非常喜欢迈克尔和德怀特对手戏中这种动态的转变。我也是。我想让你们知道，我为“107摇滚电台”做了一点深入研究。
I knew you would. I almost did, but you know what I did instead? What? I listened to Jethro Tall. Oh! There you go. I downloaded the greatest hits and listened to it, and my daughter Isbo was like,
我猜到你会这么做了。我差点也去查了，但你知道我做了什么吗？什么？我听了杰夫·罗托的歌。哦！原来如此。我下载了他们的精选集并听了，我的女儿伊斯博（Isbo）就问：
what is that? Well, they currently run contests via their free loaders club. And you can sign up with your email at rock107.com and they give away, quote, dozens of prizes each month. Here's a list of things you can win. Okay. iPads, waterpark tickets, concert tickets, gas and grocery gifts, and snow tube passes,
那是什么？好吧，他们目前通过他们的“免费加载者俱乐部”（freeloaders club）举办竞赛。你可以在 rock107.com 上用你的电子邮件注册，他们每个月会送出，引述原话，“几十个奖品”。以下是你可以赢得的奖品列表。好的。iPad、水上乐园门票、演唱会门票、汽油和杂货礼品卡，以及雪地轮胎滑雪通票，
maybe for the polka nose? Maybe. Those are great gifts, though. I know. So it goes. It's in 107. It seems like instead of doing these live contests on the area where you have to call in like Dwight did, you can just sign up with your email
也许是去波科诺斯山的？也许吧。不过这些都是很棒的礼物。我知道。所以就是这样。它在107电台。看起来与其像德怀特那样必须打电话参与这种现场竞赛，你只需用邮箱注册，
and you're automatically entered. So just giving a plug for that, give away, rock 107. Way to go. I have 10 minutes, 44 seconds. OK. Pam and Roy are flirting at reception and Jim is watching her in the kitchen. He tries to go to the annex, but he sees Kelly. Then he goes to the bathroom.
就能自动获得参与资格。所以顺便为那个抽奖活动打个广告，107摇滚电台。干得好。在10分钟44秒处。好的。帕姆和罗伊在前台调情，而吉姆在厨房看着她。他试图去附楼，但他看到了凯莉。然后他去了洗手间。
With his coffee mug. This is how trapped he is. One way is Pam and Roy. The other way is Kelly, chatty, chatty, chatty. So he just walks in the bathroom with his coffee mug. Yeah. And later, he can't eat in the lunchroom because Pam's sitting in there with Roy.
手里还拿着他的咖啡马克杯。他被逼得有多惨。一条路是帕姆和罗伊。另一条路是凯莉，喋喋不休，喋喋不休，喋喋不休。所以他只能拿着咖啡马克杯走进了洗手间。是的。后来，他没法在休息室吃午饭，因为帕姆正和罗伊坐在里面。
This leads to the deleted scene you were talking about. With him eating alone in his car. Yeah. Poor Jim. Coyce. Poor Jim. Poor Jim. So within an 11-minute, seven seconds,
这就引出了我们刚才讨论的那个被删减片段。他一个人在车里吃午饭。是的。可怜的吉姆。真惨。可怜的吉姆。可怜的吉姆。所以在11分7秒时，
Michael goes back to accounting and he's like, hey, guys, and I'm really snarky. This is like very Angela Martin snarky moment. I'm like, we haven't finished getting things in order from your last visit. And he's like, I'm just walking around and I go, where are you? I'm so ticked off.
迈克尔回到了会计部，他说：“嘿，伙计们。”而我表现得非常刻薄。这就像是一个非常具有安吉拉·马丁式刻薄的时刻。我说：“我们还没把上次你来过之后弄乱的东西收拾好呢。”然后他说：“我只是在随便走走，”我说：“你在哪儿呢？”我气坏了。
You're so mad. Well, this is when Michael gets this big idea to host a sales contest. Well, listen, because he says, we're all there working for the weekend, but you know what? He's working for the week What working for the week? He's working for the week and he wants the sales contest now and the prize is a $100 bill not
你太生气了。好吧，这就是迈克尔萌生举办销售竞赛这个宏大想法的时候。好吧，听着，因为他说，我们都在那里为了周末而工作，但你知道吗？他为了这一周而工作 怎么为了这一周而工作？他为了这一周而工作，他现在就想要销售竞赛，而奖品是一张100美元的钞票，不
Not really. He opens his wallet and he only has $83 wait Jenna before we get into the sales competition I do have some journal entries from this when do you want them? Do you want them now? No, I'm late us. I say have some journal entries from this. When do you want them? Do you want them now? Now. Now. Lay us. I say now. Now. Not lay us. Okay. Here's my journal entry for the carpet. I was really excited.
其实并没有。他打开钱包，发现只有83美元。等等，珍娜，在我们进入销售比赛之前，我确实有一些关于这个的日记记录，你什么时候想要？你现在想要吗？不，我说的是“慢着”（lay us）。我说有一些关于这个的日记记录。你什么时候想要？你现在想要吗？现在。现在。慢着。我说的是现在。现在。不是慢着。好吧。这是我关于地毯的日记。我当时真的很兴奋。
I was like, I wrote this on January 26, 2006. We got great news. We're coming back for season three. Is this the episode where we found out? Yes. Oh my gosh. So we were so excited. All of us. I don't know if you can tell in watching the episode, but we just found out we got another job for another year. That is such that's a fast fact, Angela right there. Oh, well, I liked your game
就像，我是在2006年1月26日写的。我们得到了好消息。我们要回归第三季了。这是我们得知消息的那一集吗？是的。哦天哪。所以我们都太兴奋了。我们所有人。我不知道你看这一集的时候能不能看出来，但我们刚刚得知我们又多了一年的工作。安吉拉，这真是一个“快速事实”。哦，好吧，我喜欢你从“快速事实”
from the fast fact, but there that I guess is a fast fact. Also, I said that we're just so excited. We're really proud of the show. we're so excited to get a third year. I said this week also, we had a photographer from NBC taking official photos for the website for Valentine's Day. I remember those photos. These are sort of some iconic photos that are out there on the internet of like Steve holding up a heart and Kate Flannery and you and me and Phyllis all surrounding him. Yeah. So there's some great Valentine's shot. There's one of like Dwight and I side by side. I did some photos with David Denman as Roy. So some Pam and Roy Valentine's shots as well. And I also wrote, this was the first time the supporting cast were included in one of these
里提到的那个游戏，不过我想那也是一个快速事实。另外，我说过我们太兴奋了。我们为这部剧感到非常自豪。我们很高兴能迎来第三年。我还说这周NBC的一位摄影师为情人节官网拍了官方照片。我记得那些照片。互联网上流传着一些标志性的照片，比如史蒂夫举着一颗心，凯特·弗兰内利、你、我和菲利斯都围在他周围。是的。所以有一些很棒的情人节合影。有一张是德怀特和我并肩而站的。我还和扮演罗伊的戴维·丹曼拍了一些照片。所以也有一些帕姆和罗伊的情人节照片。我还写道，这是配角第一次被纳入其中一幅
big photo shoots and we were all so excited. I remember that because we weren't series regular the last time we did them. But now we're in. We got to be in the pictures and I said of course I had the biggest zit since I've had since high school Yeah, that always happens. They probably photoshopped it out. I said I hope they'll photoshop it out I see like that like I said I know Anyway, those are oh and then I wrote and this is before you know Obviously we ever knew we'd do this podcast
大型照片拍摄中，我们当时都太兴奋了。我记得那是因为上次我们拍的时候还不是剧集常规演员。但现在我们加入了。我们得以出现在照片里，然后我说我当然长了自高中以来最大的青春痘。是的，总是这样。他们可能用P图把它去掉了。我说我希望他们会把它P掉，我看到就像那个我说我知道不管怎样，那些是哦，然后我写道，这是在你（显然）知道我们以后会做这个播客之前
We ever knew that we'd be tracking the Mindy of it all. And this is what I wrote in 2006. Okay. If you're a Kelly fan, you will love this episode. And Mindy who plays Kelly does a great job. Hey, even you knew something special is happening with the character of Kelly in the carpet. 2006 me knew that Kelly was maybe Kelly, was maybe Mindy.
我们以前知道我们会关注明迪的动态。这是我在2006年写的。好吧。如果你是凯莉的粉丝，你会喜欢这一集。饰演凯莉的明迪表现得很棒。嘿，连你都知道凯莉这个角色在《地毯》中会有特别的事情发生。2006年的我知道凯莉也许就是凯莉，也许就是明迪。
All right, let's take a break. We'll be back in a sec. Okay. All right, so back to the episode, I have a continuity catch. Okay. At 12 minutes, 43 seconds, Roy and Darrell are removing Michael's carpet. Okay.
好了，我们休息一下。一会儿回来。好的。好吧，回到这一集，我发现了一个穿帮镜头。好的。在12分43秒时，罗伊和达里尔正在搬走迈克尔的地毯。好的。
They've got this rolled up carpet on their shoulders and they make fun of his dancing. But then, at 13 minutes, 12 seconds, there's a shot of them through the blinds in Michael's office, and they're having beers and they're kind of sleeping. They're sleeping on the rolled up carpet that they just removed. They're using it as a headrest. Yeah. Well, they're sleeping on the rolled up carpet that they just remove. They're using it as a headrest. Yeah. Well, there's continuity catch. Well, and less, is that the new carpet
他们把卷起来的地毯扛在肩膀上，还取笑他的舞蹈。但是接着，在13分12秒时，有一个通过迈克尔办公室百叶窗拍摄他们的镜头，他们正在喝啤酒，而且有点在睡觉。他们睡在他们刚刚搬走的卷起来的地毯上。他们把它当作头枕。是的。好吧，他们睡在他们刚刚搬走的卷起来的地毯上。他们把它当作头枕。是的。好吧，有一个穿帮镜头。好吧，或者说，那是他们
they haven't put down yet? I don't know, but there is a whole deleted scene of just Darryl and Roy just being idiots in that room. There's a whole scene where they are drinking beers and they have two like rubber balls and they're bouncing them against the wall like they've got a game going. Yeah.
还没铺上的新地毯吗？我不知道，但里面有一整段被删减的场景，就是达里尔和罗伊在那个房间里当笨蛋。有一整场戏，他们在大口喝啤酒，手里拿着两个橡胶球，把它们砸向墙壁，就像在玩游戏一样。是的。
So there were things cut out of this episode of them messing around in there. Well, I suppose it could be the carpet they haven't installed yet. Maybe. Maybe Jenna. At 13 minutes, 56 seconds, I declare Michael Sass. Michael Sass, let's hear it.
所以这一集中剪掉了一些他们在里面胡闹的内容。好吧，我猜那可能是他们还没安装的地毯。也许吧。也许吧，珍娜。在13分56秒时，我宣布迈克尔耍性子了。迈克尔耍性子了，让我们听听。
Well, Pam says stopping the sales contest isn't fair. I guess we should say Michael gets upset and he stops his sales contest. No one can win $83 anymore. He's just being a brat. But Michael gives it right back to Pam. Oh, yeah. Yeah. I didn't write down what he said, but you can look it up at 13 minutes, 56 seconds if you want.
好吧，帕姆说停止销售竞赛不公平。我想我们应该说迈克尔不高兴了，他停止了销售竞赛。再也没有人能赢得83美元了。他只是在耍小孩脾气。但迈克尔立刻回击了帕姆。哦，对。是的。我没有写下他说的话，但如果你想的话，可以在13分56秒时去查查看。
That sort of takes a wind out of here. It does. I realize I was looking at my sheet. I was like, wow, that was an incomplete, I did not complete that question of my homework. Oh, well, I will say this. My sister and I laughed actually, she's a school teacher. She teaches pre-K and at 14 minutes, 26 seconds, Michael puts the whole office in time out.
这有点让人泄气。确实如此。我发现我正在看我的表格，心想，哇，那真是一项不完整的工作，我没有完成家庭作业的那个问题。哦，好吧，我得这么说：我和我姐姐笑了，实际上，她是一名学校老师。她教学前班，在14分26秒时，迈克尔让整个办公室的人都去罚站。
Oh, yes. Oh, yes. Anyway, okay. So then we have the scene in the kitchen with Jim and Ryan and Jim asks Ryan what he thinks of Kelly. He's trying to help Kelly out, because she's begged him. Well, this also just shows where he's at in his day
哦，是的。哦，是的。不管怎样，好吧。接下来是吉姆和瑞恩在厨房里的场景，吉姆问瑞恩对凯莉有什么看法。他试图帮凯莉一把，因为她苦苦哀求他。好吧，这也正好表明了他那一天的状态
because at first he doesn't wanna help her. He's like, I'm not getting the middle of those two. And then by the end of the day, he's like, fine, I'll be your go between. Because he doesn't have his buddy, he doesn't have Pam to like help the day pass. Well, we had a fan question. Maddie W. and Adrian both asked,
因为一开始他不想帮忙。他说，我才不蹚这两人之间的浑水。然后到了傍晚，他说，好吧，我当你们中间的传话人。因为他没有他的好哥们，他没有帕姆来帮他打发时间。好吧，我们有一个粉丝提问。马蒂·W和阿德里安都问了，
whose idea was it for Kelly to have a crush on Ryan? What do you think, Ange? I think it was Mindy's. I don't know. I was gonna text her, but she had the Oscars and she was presenting, I don't wanna bug her. Yeah, we were prepping this episode, the weekend of Oscars weekend. And Nindi was a presenter.
凯莉暗恋瑞恩是谁的主意？你觉得呢，安吉？我觉得是明迪的主意。我不知道。我本打算给她发信息，但她要出席奥斯卡颁奖典礼，还要担任颁奖嘉宾，我不想打扰她。是的，我们筹备这一集的时候，正好是奥斯卡颁奖典礼的周末。而且明迪是颁奖嘉宾。
And can we talk for one second about how amazing she looked in her dress? She looked amazing. I actually did text her in BJ the next day. And I was like, you guys look so beautiful together. Yeah. And she wrote back, and I love this. Thank you. Well, there you go. Kelly and Ryan went to the Oscars together. Well, they're very, very dear friends.
我们能花一秒钟讨论一下她穿的那件礼服有多惊艳吗？她看起来太惊艳了。我第二天确实给她和BJ发了信息。我说，你们俩站在一起真好看。是的。她回信了，我好喜欢这个。谢谢。好吧，就这样。凯莉和瑞恩一起去参加了奥斯卡颁奖典礼。好吧，他们是非常非常亲密的朋友。
They're best friends. They're best friends. There were a lot of friendships that came out of our show. There was our best friendship. There was their best friendship. Well, all of the guys still play fantasy football together. That's true. All the guys, every year.
他们是最好的朋友。我们的剧里诞生了许多友谊。有我们的至臻友谊。有他们的至臻友谊。好吧，所有的伙计们现在还在一起玩梦幻足球。那是真的。所有的伙计们，每年都这样。
All right, so where are we at, Jonah? So next, Michael talks to Creed about his fear of becoming Ed Truck. Oh, this scene is so funny. Creed made me laugh so hard in the scene. Yeah. He's like, Michael, you have a lot more to be worried about than that. He's like, oh great, thanks Creed.
好吧，我们到哪儿了，珍娜？接下来，迈克尔跟克里德谈了他对变成埃德·特ruck的恐惧。哦，这一幕太搞笑了。在这场戏里，克里德把我逗得哈哈大笑。是的。他说，迈克尔，你该担心的事情可比这多得多。他说，哦太好了，谢谢克里德。
I guess being buried alive. Why am I even talking to you? And then we go outside and we meet Ed truck. And this scene, oh, it broke my heart because in the scene Ed says, Michael, why can't your workers be your workers, your family be your family, and your friends be your friends? And you can see they hold on Michael's face.
我猜是被活埋。我为什么还要跟你说话？然后我们走到外面，遇到了埃德·特拉克。这一幕，哦，让我心碎，因为在这一幕里，埃德说，迈克尔，为什么你的员工不能是你的员工，你的家人不能是你的家人，你的朋友不能是你的朋友？你可以看到镜头定格在迈克尔的脸上。
And you can see that the reason why is because he doesn't have friends and family. He needs his workers to be all three things. He doesn't have those compartments in his life. No, he doesn't. And it breaks your heart. It breaks your heart for him. Oh, well, speaking of heartbreak, 17 minutes, eight seconds.
你可以看到原因是他既没有朋友也没有家人。他需要他的员工同时具备这三种身份。他的生活中没有那些划分界限的格子。不，他没有。这真让人心碎。让人为他感到心碎。哦，说到心碎，17分08秒。
So this is like cut in between Michael's talking head, Jim is in the kitchen, which kind of looks like Jim hung out in the kitchen all day. I think he spent a lot of time in there. Not only that guys, but if you look at this episode, John didn't have very many lines. This was not a tough like line count for him as far as like memory work.
所以这就像是穿插在迈克尔的单人访谈之间，吉姆在厨房里，看起来吉姆好像一整天都在厨房里晃悠。我觉得他在那儿花了很长的时间。不仅如此，伙计们的，如果你看这一集，约翰的台词其实不多。就记忆工作而言，这对他的台词量来说并不是一场硬仗。
All of his stuff was reacting for the most part in this episode. So but anyway, during Michael's talking head, we see Jim is in the kitchen and he tries to wave goodbye to Pam. Pam doesn't see it and just leaves. And it's like the last just like wind out of his sails for the day. She kind of leaves early. She's got her big puffy coat on and everyone else is still working, but she sneaks out.
在这一集里，他的大部分戏份基本上都是在做出反应。不过无论如何，在迈克尔的单人访谈期间，我们看到吉姆在厨房里，他试图向帕姆挥手告别。帕姆没看见，直接走了。这就像是他当天的最后一点心气也被抽空了。她有点提前走了。她穿着那件大大的膨膨羽绒服，其他所有人还在工作，但她溜走了。
Yeah. And what does he do after that? He calls Brenda. Oh, God, it's so desperate. From Booze Cruise. It's the corporate liaison. And asks her on a date. And Kelly's, Kelly, Mindy's reactions as Kelly to this phone call were so fantastic. So great. He calls an astronaut a date. And then he's like, and you can just, you know, I got your number from the company directory. And I guess you could get my number from the company directory I said directory. Oh, what are you doing? Check your email because I just emailed you okay? Hope to hear from you. Okay
是的。那他之后做了什么？他打电话给布伦达。哦，天哪，太绝望了。来自《游艇派对》的那位。那是公司的联络人。约她出去。凯莉，凯莉，明迪作为凯莉对这个电话的反应太棒了。太棒了。他约一个宇航员（注：此处口误，实际应为联络员Brenda）出去约会。然后他说，你可以，你知道的，我从公司名册上得到了你的号码。我想你也可以从公司名册上得到我的号码，我说的是名册。哦，你在干嘛？检查你的电子邮件，因为我刚给你发了邮件，好吗？希望能听到你的回复，好吗？
Yeah, and Kelly's like did you just ask a girl out over a voicemail? He's like yep Michael's talking head in this episode. He has a huge talking head that I love and I wrote it all down. Here it is. Last week I would have given a kidney to anyone in the office. I would have reached right into my stomach and pulled it out for them. But now? No, I don't have the relationship with these people that I thought I did. I hope they ask. So they can hear me say, oh, no, I only give my organs to my real friends. Go get yourself a monkey kidney. Oh my God. He's so mad. He's so mad. He's so hurt.
是的，然后凯莉说：你刚刚是在语音信箱里约女孩子出去吗？他说：对啊。迈克尔在这一集里的单人访谈。他有一段很长的单人访谈，我非常喜欢，我把它全写下来了。就是这样。上周我愿意把一颗肾脏捐给办公室里的任何人。我会直接把手伸进肚子里把它掏出来送给他们。但现在呢？不，我和这些人之间并没有我想象的那种关系。我希望他们问我。这样他们就能听到我说，哦，不，我只把器官留给我真正的朋友。你自己去弄个猴子肾吧。哦，天哪。他太生气了。他太生气了。他太受伤了。
He feels so betrayed. He would have, he really would have given them one of his organs. You know he would have. Yeah. He would have. Now he's only gonna give you a monkey kidney. Poor Michael. Poor Michael. And then at 18 minutes, 20 seconds, guess who calls? Todd Packer. Todd Packer. Did you get that package I left for you? He's like, what package? Did I get package? Anybody see a package? He's always like, do you mean the thing? The thing in your office? And Michael's delighted! Oh, what a funny prank! Oh, someone loves me, they wanna do jokes,
他觉得自己被背叛了。他本来会，他真的会把自己的一个器官送给他们。你知道他会的。是的。他会的。现在他只打算给你一颗猴子肾。可怜的迈克尔。可怜的迈克尔。然后到了18分20秒，你猜谁打来的？托德·帕克。托德·帕克。你拿到我留给你的包裹了吗？他说，什么包裹？我拿到包裹了吗？有人看到包裹吗？他总是说，你是说那个东西吗？你办公室里的那个东西？迈克尔高兴坏了！哦，多有趣的恶作剧！哦，有人爱我，他们想开玩笑，
they wanna poop on my floor. So funny, when Packer does it, it's a hilarious, funny prank. No, when Packer does it, he says it, 19 minutes, 13 seconds, it was done out of love. Just like, just like I thought. We just thought what he thought. Oh, he's not what he thought. But I do think he's so relieved that it was no one in the office.
他们想在我的地板上拉大便。太搞笑了，帕克做这事的时候，就是一个爆笑又有趣的恶作剧。不，帕克做这事的时候，他说了，19分13秒，这是出于爱意才做的。就像，就像我想的那样。我们只是这么想的，正如他所想的那样。哦，他可不是他想的那样。但我确实觉得，得知这不是办公室里的任何人干的，他大大松了一口气。
Well, everything is right again, right? His universe makes sense again. This is my family. They wouldn't do that. It's just crazy Todd Packer. Everything's okay. Well, then, can we talk about the sweetest of sweet moments? Yes, I did write my journal.
好吧，一切又恢复正常了，对吧？他的宇宙又说得通了。这是我的家人。他们不会做出那种事。这只是疯狂的托德·帕克。一切都好。好吧，那么，我们能谈谈那些最甜蜜的时刻吗？是的，我写了我的日记。
I said, guys, I don't want to give anything away, but this has one of the sweetest endings of an episode yet. So this whole episode, we've given you no indication that Pam is clocking Jim in any way. And anyway, but Jim walks to his desk. He sees the little message light flashing and he plays his messages and Pam has left him seven voice mails. All about her day. And clearly she's missing him and missing interacting with him.
我说，伙计们，我不想剧透，但这是剧集中结局最甜蜜的一集之一。所以整整这一集，我们都没有给出任何迹象表明帕姆在某种程度上对吉姆动了心。无论如何，吉姆走向他的办公桌。他看到小留言灯在闪烁，于是播放了他的语音留言，帕姆给他留了七条语音留言。全都是关于她的一天。很明显她在想念他，也想念和他在一起的互动。
Yeah, and you see him kind of walk to his car as these messages play. And his face. Ah, he's so happy. Yeah. And everything is right in his world again. And kind of everything is right in our world again too, because I think as an audience member,
是的，随着这些留言的播放，你可以看到他朝自己的车走去。他的表情。啊，他太开心了。是的。他的世界又一切正常了。而且某种程度上，我们世界里的情况也一切正常了，因为我认为作为观众，
it's funny, I forgot about the voicemail messages when I was watching this. Yeah. And I was frustrated with Pam. I was like, what is wrong with you? This is your friend, why are you being so coy? I skied a little and then like, say hi to the guy. I wasn't upset with Pam because I feel like she's,
说来好笑，我在看这一集的时候把语音留言的事给忘了。是的。而且我对帕姆感到沮丧。我想，你到底怎么了？这是你的朋友，你为什么这么忸怩作态？我滑了一会儿雪，然后就像，跟那家伙打个招呼呗。我对帕姆并不感到不安，因为我觉得她，
this is so complicated for her. I mean, I'm sure there's hills and valleys of her wanting to invest in Roy and what they've built together and see it through. And then there's all these overwhelming feelings of like, but I don't think he's the right person, but we've been together so long. Like it's, and then when she sees Jim,
这对她来说太复杂了。我的意思是，我确信她内心经历着高低起伏，既想投入到罗伊以及他们共同建立的感情中并坚持到底。然后又涌现出各种势不可挡的情感，比如，但我觉得他不是对的人，可我们在一起这么久了。这就像是，然后当她看到吉姆时，
she's, it's like holding up a mirror to herself. I think you're telling me she didn't miss him on the vacation. Yes, but admitting to missing him is admitting to this emotional affair and she's not there yet. She's not there yet, but these messages meant the world to me as a viewer when I was watching it. Yes, I was like, yes, thank you. Thank you. And also guys, once again, I feel like Michael and Jim had a parallel storyline, where they sort of lose the thing they love, which is for Michael, the acceptance of the office's friends, for Jim, it's Pam. But then in the end, it's all OK.
她，这就好像是在照一面镜子。你是说你在告诉我她在度假时没有想念他？是的，但是承认想念他就是承认这场情感出轨，而她还没到那一步。她还没到那一步，但作为一个观众，当我在观看时，这些留言对我来说有着非凡的意义。是的，当时我就想，太棒了，谢谢你。谢谢你。而且伙计们，再说一次，我觉得迈克尔和吉姆有着平行的故事情节，他们都在某种程度上失去了他们所爱的东西，对迈克尔来说，是办公室里作为朋友的认可，对吉姆来说，是帕姆。但最后，一切都好。
It's going to be OK. Yeah. Nah. Aw, that's the carpet, guys. That's the carpet, everybody. I have a question. I want to throw it out there. Actually, do we need to start a second podcast where I rewatch Game of Thrones and we
一切都会好起来的。是的。啊。啊，那是地毯，伙计们。那是地毯，各位。我有一个问题。我想抛出来。实际上，我们需要开启第二个播客吗？在那里我重看《权力的游戏》，然后我们
discuss it with you? Yes. Yes. Office ladies do Game of Thrones. Oh my gosh, I would love that so much. I mean, does anyone want to hear that? Does anyone want to hear me listen to Game of Thrones? Although, there might be some.
和你一起讨论它？是的。是的。《办公室女士》做《权力的游戏》。哦天哪，我太喜欢了。我是说，有人想听那个吗？有人想听我听《权力的游戏》吗？不过，可能会有一些。
Listen to me watch Game of Thrones. Die Hard Game of Thrones fans will be like, no, you guys are gonna ruin it. All right, next week we're gonna do Boys and Girls, which is a very exciting episode for Angela and I will tell you all about how we had a hand in creating this episode. Yes, see you next week.
听我观看《权力的游戏》。《权力的游戏》的死忠粉会觉得，不，你们会把它毁了的。好吧，下周我们要讨论《男孩与女孩》，这对安吉拉和我来说是非常令人兴奋的一集，我会向你们讲述我们是如何参与创作这一集的。好的，下周见。
See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies! Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher, our sound engineer Sam Keifer. And our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Bratton. For at free versions of the show and our bonus episodes Candy Bag, go to stitur premium.com. For a free one month trial of stitupremium, use code office. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》！《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍妮弗和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔，音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的节目以及我们的彩蛋剧集《糖果袋》，请访问stitur premium.com。要免费试用stitu premium一个月，请使用代码office。该剧集尚无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。